[Applause]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
takes you on an expedition down into the
theorists cave of wisdom readjust
stalagmite learn something new
dreadful speleology puns aside that's
the science of studying caves by the way
today I want to dust off what is for my
money one of the most underappreciated
movies in the 21st century of horror
canon the descent in an era that didn't
have the greatest track record with
horror how did your pond get off the
bike step away from the bike the descent
stood out for it's claustrophobic
setting smart characterization and
horror that didn't depend solely on
monsters popping out to kill you if you
haven't seen it the descent is about a
group of friends who go on a trip in the
Appalachian Mountains to get in on that
sweet sweet spelunking action the leader
of the group decides that safety and
responsibility are lame so she leads the
team down into an unexplored section of
the caves and wouldn't you know it the
entrance promptly collapses trapping
them inside someone call Elon Musk up in
this his house build these gals a
submarine anyway their day goes from bad
to worse as the group eventually
realizes that they're being hunted by
albino cave goblins cold crawlers who
are blind and hunt by sound and
definitely weren't ripped off exactly by
the monsters of a quiet place from that
point forward the movie becomes a
frantic race in the dark winding caves
to escape before everyone becomes a
crawler snack the movie was followed
three years later by the descent part to
a straight-to-dvd sequel which is mostly
a retread of the first movie except now
there's a scene where the heroes fall
into the crawlers toilet and get pooped
on which is also pretty much what it
feels like to watch the descent part 2
so yeah the sequel not great but the
original descent is a solid movie sure
the poster is super cheesy like a guess
it kind of looks like a skull if you
really squint at it but
and the art team was really reaching
hard for this one but it is a movie that
has a little bit of everything that you
like about horn tension claustrophobia
some gross score and a really
frightening monster and it's that last
one that I want to focus on today
because the crawlers in the descent find
this really interesting middle ground as
far as horror monsters go they aren't
fantasy killers like Freddy Krueger but
they're also not very very plausible
monsters like the shark from Jaws
they're kind of realistic but kinda not
they seem like the kind of thing that
would be a local legend like Bigfoot or
the Blair Witch or the Jersey Devil and
so unapologetic theorists an amateur
Monster Hunter that I am I wanted to
figure out whether the crawlers could
actually be real how plausible is it
that there are blind
albino humanoid hunters living amongst
us feeding in the unexplored cave
systems right under our feet strap on
your headlamps use your inside voices
and bring some hand sanitizer in case
you fall into a gremlin latrine because
we're diving headfirst into the unknowns
no no you stop at Disney this is not
your theory you have every other movie
franchise out there I'm not letting you
have this one you had your chance and
you decided not to release anything no
bad Disney you're on timeout you give me
something better than Artemis Fowl and
then we'll talk to start our monster
hunt we first have to know what exactly
we're looking for we get many many good
looks at the crawlers over the course of
the descent movies so we know for sure
that they kind of looked like a mix
between Nosferatu and that war monster
from that one episode of the x-files but
the movies themselves don't actually
give us much of an explanation of what
they are or where they came from
luckily for us though the director the
first movie Neil Marshall has gone on
record to provide a bit more detail
about the crawlers in an interview
promoting the release of the first movie
Marshall said that quote the crawlers
are cavemen that didn't leave the cave
they've evolved in this environment over
thousands of years and there's a
community of them that lived down there
in families they've lost their eyesight
they have acute hearing and smell and
they function perfectly in the
pitch-black and quote I uh I gotta be
honest that is a lot more comprehensive
of an explanation than I was expecting
then all of those characteristics are
indeed represented across the movies
with the possible exception being the
one about the acute sense of smell one
scene in particular shows a crawler
nearly on top of two of the spelunker
but because they stay still and stay
quiet the crawler doesn't realize
they're there which doesn't really make
sense if he can actually smell them so
maybe not that one but the rest of his
statement gives us plenty of stuff to
fact-check about cave people
sensory evolution cryptids and so forth
so could crawlers exist in the real
world without us knowing it let's start
with issue number one unexplored caves
where the crawlers could hide when we
think about exploring the world it
always seems like that's something that
just sort of stopped at some point in
the past sure those dummies in the 1500s
had no idea about how many continents
there were but now we've mapped out the
whole place and that's not true it's not
true in the slightest truth be told
there are tons of unexplored places all
over the world and we're still
discovering new massive cave systems
each and every year here's a giant one
in Canada that's been nicknamed the
Sarlacc pit that nobody knew existed
just two years ago
a big cave was discovered in Colorado
earlier this year and that's not even
considering potential off shooting caves
from the ones that we already know exist
so the notion that if crawlers existed
especially here in the US that we know
about them already it just isn't
necessarily true these unexplored an
undiscovered cave systems aren't even in
remote parts of the world where nobody
lives depending on where you're watching
this video it's possible that there's
unexplored cave systems under your feet
right now waiting to fall open and
expose you to the hungry crawlers
underneath don't look down
haha major look at your feet issue
number two discovering new animal
species it's easy to think that if
understanding and cataloguing the earth
is our homework we've been done for
years but that just simply isn't true
there were 71 new plant and animal
species discovered in 2019 alone some of
which were discovered underground and in
caves like this spider that worships
ants you heard that right and no I'm not
gonna explain that just this year there
was a new giant cave fish uncovered if
cataloging all the living things and
places on earth is our homework we're
gonna need to pull an all-nighter here
folks according to an article by
National Geographic some scientists
estimate that 86 percent of living
organisms on earth still haven't been
classified by humankind now it's true
that a lot of that 86 percent is likely
made up of things like rare fungi and
bacteria that only live in volcanoes are
weird fish that walk along the bottom of
the ocean and look like they're wearing
lipstick oh wait we actually did find
that one at any rate maybe you think
that it's just too unlikely that a large
bipedal animal like the crawlers would
go undiscovered for this long and for
that I turn your attention to almost
exactly one year ago today when a new
species of ancient human was discovered
inside a cave system in the Philippines
the homo luzon Ensis thought to have
been under 4 feet or 1.2 meters tall and
adapted to climbing trees and what are
those crawlers in the descent again oh
yeah short humanoid hunters living in
caves and adept at climbing in 2006 when
the Descent first came out these were
fictional monsters fourteen years later
here in 2020 we have bones and a species
name to show that those crawlers might
not be so fictitious after all the moral
of the story here is that big animals
can go undiscovered for a long time
especially if they're the type of big
animal that kills you when you discover
them so let's keep going down this
threat say homo lose and Ensis this
prototype human is indeed our candidate
for what would eventually become the
descents crawlers what about their
senses as I mentioned before the
crawlers are blind if we're saying that
the crawlers are essentially these
protohumans isn't realistic to believe
that a subspecies of human would
basically evolve away their eyesight
well yeah it is more than plausible
there are species of fish and
crustaceans that have lost both their
pigmentation and their eyesight because
they live in caves
in caves skin pigment and eyesight are
just wasted evolutionary supplies and
once you know it those species are found
in the Appalachian cave systems the same
location that the crawlers haunt in the
descent and while totally blind mammals
are more rare they do in fact exist as
in the case of the star-nosed mole as a
side note boy was i relieved to find out
that this thing is the size of a hamster
because when I first saw close-up of
this thing I thought it was here to rip
open my face and eat my brain it's like
a real-life version of the demagogue and
from stranger things so to answer the
question of whether protohumans like the
homo luzon Ensis could evolve over time
to go completely blind develop
themselves super
and lose all skin pigmentation it is a
decided yes homo lose and Ensis has been
dated to have existed in those caves
fifty thousand to sixty seven thousand
years ago which leaves plenty of time to
adapt to your surroundings now
admittedly scientists are still unsure
about the exact genetic mechanisms that
lead to blindness and certain animals
but there is no doubt that it happens to
organisms that previously have those
senses given enough time enough darkness
enough isolation it is certainly
plausible that the crawlers could have
evolved that way over tens of thousands
of years so then last question what
about food one of my initial thoughts
was that the crawlers would eventually
starve to death because waiting for dumb
hikers to stumble town into your
unexplored cave ain't a good survival
strategy and finding enough food inside
of a cave to sustain a human-sized
monster would be pretty hard
there's a reason Caves are full of small
creatures finding tons of insects to
feed something like a bat sure not a
problem finding enough food to sustain a
mini human now that becomes an issue but
it's also an issue that the movies
disprove for me in the descent part to
goblin Boogaloo we see near the end of
movie that the crawlers actually hunt
above ground particularly on deer and
then they drag those kills back into the
cave to feast on that means they aren't
relying on what's solely inside the cave
as a food supply and if they're going
after deer well they don't even have to
hunt anymore
there are approximately a million
collisions with deer every year in the
United States alone so realistically
those crawlers might be cleaning more
deer carcasses off the highway than the
transportation department so many they
might as well get themselves one of
those adopt-a-highway sines dedicated to
um if the crawlers have a clean water
source which caves tend to and can hunt
and scavenge under the cover of darkness
resources for these guys aren't gonna be
that big of a deal
so is that it did we just check off all
the boxes did I just unintentionally
sign myself up to become a crawler
truther navigating the caves of Greater
Appalachia and apparently also the
Philippines in search of modern-day
Morlocks
stand aside ghost hunters move away
Finding Bigfoot it's time for crawler
quest to rise up featuring your host
literally anyone other than me cuz lord
knows ain't squeezing my dad bought into
those tiny caves No
the real killer of this theory isn't the
crawlers themselves it's actually
genetics in ecology there's a concept
known as minimum viable population or
MVP for short that considers how many
individual organisms are required for
the long-term survival of a species it
depends a bit on the type of animal rat
and bugs have small MVPs because they
can make quickly and often whereas
animals like humans with a long juvenile
period and fewer reproductive partners
have higher MVPs so what is the exact
MVP numbers of humans or in this case
crawler humans that would need to exist
for the population to survive there are
some competing theories among scientists
who are currently theorizing about our
ability to colonize other planets one
estimate puts the number at 98 another
one puts it at 14000 so um let's hope we
knew that number down just a wee bit
before we make that big trip to Mars
Halloween even if we go with the most
bare-bones route and say we need about a
hundred crawlers for our homo losin n
says to continue on in the cave system
it doesn't bode well for them the most
we ever see on screen at one time is 9
near the end of the movie and
anthropologists believe that cave
dwelling Neanderthals only lived in
groups between 10 and 30 individuals
pretty likely that the crawlers are
below the MVP that they need to survive
so what would happen in smaller
populations well I hope that this
soundbite doesn't get taken out of
context but the answer is massive
inbreeding inbreeding in human
populations leads to a number of
different problems in the offspring from
low birth rates to physical
abnormalities to heart failure but
there's one side effect of inbreeding
that really hurts the chances for
crawlers and that's hearing loss
studies show much higher rates of
deafness in populations with
intermarriage and inbreeding so if the
crawlers are blind and then going deaf
and they also can't smell their prey
when they're right on top of them
they're just not gonna be able to
survive very long it looks like my cave
hunting ended before it even began or
not you know Finding Bigfoot lasted a
hundred episodes and they were just
literally wandering around in the woods
with night-vision cameras the whole time
it was like Blair Witch lame edition so
there you have it friends no crawlers in
the caves ghosts belong to your
it's content without a care in the world
except for caves collapsing extreme
claustrophobia and giant bat eating
centipedes happy caving but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and cuts
you